while we were planning this conference
we had to squeeze it in between
rosh hashanah
and september 11th
and
we're in new york city so september 11th
has had a profound impact on our city
and we were trying to think of the best
way to
discuss this because um
many of you were living here at the time
i'm sure many of you weren't also but
love you with a lifelong new yorkers you
were here you know definitely had a
profound impact and changed the whole
country changed the world but it
happened here in our city
so i'm going to bring up to the stage
for a special message
from major dusty turner who has spoken
at the conference before and used to
teach at west point just up the river
from where we are
so please welcome dusty
thanks jared i appreciate it and uh
thank you for
for this opportunity as jared mentioned
my name is uh major dusty turner and i'm
a former engineer officer
and i'm currently an operations research
systems analyst for the united states
army
i as a junior in high school on a warm
uh warm tuesday morning in the small
town of center point texas was sitting
in my american history class when my
teacher turned on the television to
reveal a burning tower
we all soon learned
shortly that our nation was under attack
and almost 3 000 americans would lose
lives due to acts of terror that day
many of you as well may have been
personally or more personally affected
by the events on 11th september 2001.
perhaps you can recall exactly where you
were or what you were doing the moment
that you heard that a plane had flown
into one of the world trade towers
some of you may have been too young to
remember perhaps not even born yet but
regardless the tragic events on that day
changed our lives here in the united
states and around the globe in countless
ways
while some were passengers and others
were bystanders and many others were
first responders who lost their lives
our country united around one special
vow and that was that we would never
forget
and we will never forget
tomorrow marks the 20th anniversary of
that tragic day
i believe fully that it's appropriate
necessary and healthy to look back
both personally and as a country and
remember those events and the lives that
were lost on that day
here on the map on the screen shows the
hometowns of everyone who we lost that
day
this shows the great impact in new york
and dc and how it really affected
everyone across the country
let us take a moment to stop reflect and
never forget those who lost their lives
on september 11th 2001.
the names you were about to see are
among the
2983 individuals that lost their lives
please join me in a moment of silence to
remember them their friends their
families and the ones that they love
that they left behind
let us never forget
thank you
thank you folks um i hope that
you can have a moment to reflect on this
as we go into lunch
and we'll see you all back here at
little before